-Here with his US TV debut,
performing the number-one
Latin song in the country,
"Ella Baila Sola,"
-Give it up for Peso Pluma.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Un, dos, tres,
un, dos, tres.
♪♪
♪ Compa
¿Qué le parece esa morra? ♪
♪ La que anda bailando sola ♪
♪ Me gusta pa' mí Ella ♪
♪ Ella sabe que está buena ♪
♪ Que todos andan mirándola
como baila ♪
♪ Me acerco
y le tiro todo un verbo ♪
♪ Tomamos tragos sin peros,
solo tentación ♪
♪ Le dije ♪
♪ Ey, "Voy a conquistar
tu familia ♪
♪ que en unos días
vas a ser mía" ♪
♪ Me dijo, oh ♪
♪ Que estoy muy loco
pero le gusta ♪
♪ Que ningún vato
como yo actúa ♪
♪♪
[ Speaks in Spanish ]
Doble P.
♪♪
♪ No soy un vato
que tiene varo ♪
♪ Pero hablando del corazón,
te cumplo todo ♪
♪ Me agarró
pegadito de su mano ♪
♪ Mi compa ni se la creyó,
que al pasar fui yo ♪
♪ Su cuerpo, oh ♪
♪ Juro por Dios
que era tan perfecto ♪
♪ Su cinturita como modelo ♪
♪ Sus ojos, oh ♪
♪ Desde el principio
me enamoraron ♪
♪ A ella le gusta
y a mí me gusta ♪
♪ Hey ♪
[ Speaks in Spanish ]
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, come on! Thank you, buddy.
-Thank you.
-That is how you do
it right there.
Peso Pluma!